varados desde hace más de una semana
estos migrantes se esperan en la costa
colombiana la reapertura de las
fronteras con panamá lo que queremos es
que por favor que de algún lado no sea
alguna autoridad pertinente escuchen
nuestro nuestro pedido y que nos
faciliten la venta del tiquete para
poder nosotros cruzar y continuar sea de
haití o de cuba pero también hay
ciudadanos africanos de burkina faso
senegal y camerún entre otros instalados
en tiendas de campaña en necoclí quieren
intentar cruzar el peligroso golfo de
urabá para llegar a estados unidos pero
las autoridades locales denuncian un
riesgo sanitario para los habitantes y
piden un corredor humanitario en la
frontera los migrantes deciden la
apertura de la frontera
a continuar su viaje pero este no es un
momento para movilizarse por el
contrario es un momento para
resguardarse con el fin de minimizar los
riesgos de contagio de hoy 19 según las
autoridades migratorias la reapertura de
los vuelos internacionales por parte de
colombia y el fin del confinamiento
desde septiembre han aumentado el flujo
de inmigrantes en la zona dicen que en
los últimos meses capturaron a 198
traficantes de personas y desmantelaron
60 redes de tráfico sin embargo 4
migrantes se ahogaron a principios de
enero al hundirse una embarcación ilegal
en la zona la misma autoridad colombiana
y el alcalde no estar diciendo
prácticamente que tenemos que alquilar
una lancha
de 400 dólares grandes tinas yo no
quiero hacer eso conmigo el año pasado
colombia deportó a unos 3.800
inmigrantes ilegales la mayoría
procedentes de haití